first of the last two minutes next one
will put the Warriors at the line no
fouls to give either way Curry dancing
with Davis lost the handle keeps the
dribble 10 to shoot Curry doing it
himself here one foot fade away no good
green with a rebound tipped by Wiggins
another chance for Golden State Curry a
long three no
Walker with the rebound gotta follow him
they do
oh my goodness Curry
launched a deep three
he missed it and now the Lakers will go
to the line well he misses this first
one but Schroeders on Draymond Green on
the switch
so he gives up the offensive rebound and
then Curry
with a deep step back three and Lonnie
Walker a very good free-throw shooter 80